fyz Healthcare Organizations countries
with infection cases over 100,000 people
in is unfortunately hi I'm talking about
the United States with a figure approach
in 1 million people Spain Italy France
Germany the UK Turkey the disease
control and prevention prevention
situation varied significantly in some
countries like in Italy Spain Germany
France and the Czech Republic there was
registered rather modest relative
reduction in the number of disease cases
and legal cases in some countries on the
other hand like in the United States the
trend of infection spread was almost the
same causing dozens of thousands of new
infections and this in its turn resulted
in a lot of fatalities the effort is
still under way to render assistance to
the Russians finding themselves abroad
in a difficult situation in order to
implement resolutions and algorithms of
the operation center of the government
of the Russian Federation the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs taken actions to
return Russian citizens back home they
are based on the Disease Control and
Prevention situation and the actual
operty in it is
to accommodate people for a fortnight
quarantine in regions currently the
practice as we call it of targeted
delivery of citizens to cities and
regions is becoming more and more
widespread we also seen that the
administration of regions has become an
actively involved the MFA of Russia
receives a lot of requests from
governor's among other people to render
assistance local authorities develop
programs to provide opportunities to the
returnees to have all isolation
procedures in some cases they also cover
flight costs by taking additional
resources and they also transfer
citizens from airports to their places
of residence the government has also
taken a decision to provide financial
aid to those who are about to come back
to Russia as you're aware the MFA has
established the Commission for money
transfers to citizens and these money is
received by thousands of Russian
citizens abroad we are doing this on a
daily basis I would like to emphasize
additionally that this effort of
assistance is in no way contradicting or
replacing the returnee endeavor
according to the official information
the Russian aviation agency task force
from the 20th March the 26th of April
about 250,000 Russians returned to
Russia from abroad this is official
information from the Russian Aviation
agency according to the resolution of
the government's operation center aimed
at preventing the introduction spread of
the new coronavirus infection of the
Russian Federation after quotas for
inbound compatriots from Moscow regions
were approved on March 31st more than
14,000 people returned back home in the
context of our air
Hertz which caused a lot of interest
among the public both journalists and
the community father followed it I'm
talking about Russian schoolchildren who
stayed in the United States today I can
note it with joy that the situation is a
little more complex than it seems
originally but as of now a couple of
hours ago
sharing medieval saw the air flow its
flight arriving bringing a group of our
children the Embassy of Russia in
Washington and as I have said a group of
Russian schoolchildren have arrived our
embassy is still looking for children
who are staying in the United States we
have already explained how they find
themselves there they were there through
various the education programs their
implementation was not in any way agreed
upon with our authorities it was done
secretly effectively when the tan
demmick broke out a number of receiving
organizations suggested rather prefer to
lean alienate themselves and they asked
us to take the children as soon as
possible
the first to do that was the u.s.
Department of State who advised us on
April 6th they informed us that they
phase out secondary school student
program advertised by their website but
they provided no lists of children and
our foreign yes partners failed to give
even exact number what they said was
that there were about 80 high school
students from Russia
starting last week American diplomats
mentioned has been mentioning that less
than 30 Russian teenagers who came on
the various programs remain in the
United States well does this figure come
from
is difficult to say when and how these
children left Russia is something the
yes authorities never explained to us
they did not give us any contact details
of this children despite our official
requests however the Embassy of Russia
managed to find on its own initiative 35
schoolchildren in different states
compared to the last figure of 30 s
culture and this is higher than this
figure a significant portion of children
left New York by air float and this is
information as of now some of this
school children has agreed agreed upon
with their parents since they came from
Russian regions decided that they stay
in the United States until the
originally original departure scheduled
in May June this is the decision that
was taken by parents children and
involving our diplomats to some extent
that they that was their own personal
choice we did not persuade them somehow
or to stay or to return we proceeded
from every individual case individually
taken into account the context that we
have as of today what we can say is that
there are about 40 schoolchildren who
have returned throughout these spirits
to Russia with this flight alone 19
children returned but considering these
chaotic figures and varying information
given by American authorities we are not
going to stop looking for them all in
all all children whom we have found who
information about whom we received from
their parents or returned or decided to
stay until the expiry of their visa we
are still continuing our effort and we
cannot stop continuing this effort
because we are not fully inform about
the final number of students stay in the
United States and we are grateful to
those who follow us and inform us via
phone or any other means these
concealment of information beat
voluntary or involuntary I don't want to
discuss this now but all this makes us
consider this situation once again and
to address supervision authorities and
education establishments to be most
vigilant we cannot allow that children
are brought outside of Russia without
crystal clear responsibilities of
receiving organizations without
guarantees of states that receive them
who is in charge for the appearance of
their stay abroad who takes
responsibility
problems that we're neglected previously
we're brought up during this pandemic
outbreak and we have to draw conclusions
from it now considering the schedule of
Minister foreign affairs on the 30th of
April tomorrow the heads of Russian
Ministry is to going to take part in a
videoconference of the Normandy format
conference they will discuss a set of
implementation measure measures and the
results of the December 2019 meeting we
returned to our somewhat innovative
model of meetings but still following a
traditional schedule of the ministry
meeting the press following his
international negotiations we had this
first experience yesterday there was a
meeting of the BRICS Council of foreign
ministers following following this
meeting Sergei Lavrov had a meeting with
Russian and foreign journalists and
tomorrow based on this videoconference
we are going to have another virtual
briefing the anniversary of the victory
despite complicated circumstances due to
the pandemic outbreak to say the least
and despite sweeping quarantine measures
the Russian diplomatic missions are
still in the pipeline of adapting their
effort to the current conditions
schedules and formats of previously
planned activities on the occasion of
the 70th anniversary of the victory in
the Great Patriotic War are reconsidered
I'm talking about collective measures in
the first place
specifically a
has been decided to postpone receptions
in Russian diplomatic relations public
reed Lane ceremonies to Russian
memorial's organizations of exhibitions
performances meetings with competitors
and sports competitions in the current
epidemic context our diplomatic missions
intend to focus on Internet and media
space as a platform for activities I'm
talking about for exposition exhibition
special expositions including war video
and photo retrospective chronicles
screening of Russian feature and
documentary films as well as Great
Patriotic War problems ceremonies on the
occasion of the Victory Day will as
always be held involving representatives
of the associations of Russian can
Patras living abroad and these
activities will also be available online
the online formats will feature such
international activities as immortal
regiments candle of memory son George
ribbon additionally the Russian Russian
diplomats will take active part in local
memorial activities organized by local
authorities including online in the
current context as you're aware there
are considerable difficulties in
awarding anniversary medals on the 75th
on occasion of the 75th anniversary of
victory in the Great Patriotic War two
veterans live in abroad in this context
the foreign missions will organize
individual visits to veterans at their
place of residence and send in the
medals by post all this is done in
strict
prescriptions of local authorities
abroad and the current disease control
and prevention situation who will make
sure that on the one hand our veterans
live in abroad celebrate this date we
will make sure they are aware that
Russia celebrates this date equally that
their feed the heroic feat is always
alive in our memories and that's
something that goes through our lives
completely and at the same time we need
to focus on supporting their health and
not compromising it since it's not
impossible to organize on the 9th of May
Chronicle and other relevant activities
there are options to postpone them for
later periods for instance the permanent
nation of Russia to the United Nations
decided to postpone until autumn a photo
exhibition press at war and as well as
the gala concert see in the UN General
Assembly involving Russian music bands
and collectives the Department of
Information and press of the MFA of
Russia provides information and advisory
support as we describe it here but in
fact it is a single effort unified in
many ways we provides access to photos
compilations of materials prepared by
Russian state archive information
agencies and other materials are
available now to another international
aspect Syria but in the context of white
helmets we have repeatedly note that the
protector ship extended by Western
states and their allies to the pursuit
of humanitarian organization white
helmets affiliated with terrorist
structures active in Syria and here I
would like to draw attention to an
interview given by mr. Sara Molotov to
task media outlets
he gave a wider coverage of this topic a
couple of comments one of the most vivid
examples of such dubious foreign policy
steps is financial and political support
of these two the rescuers by Canada the
US in 2016 the head of white helmets
spoke in the Canadian Parliament what he
called for was not humanitarian aid but
military pressure of official Damascus
according to our information following
this visit Ottawa through intermarry
intermediaries provided four and a half
million US dollars to his organization
when the expectations cherished by
Western capitals in relation to the
military triumph of terrorists in the
fight against Syria's legitimate
governments will literally destroyed
resulting from a successful operation of
the Syrian Armed Forces in the country's
south Ottawa actively supported by the
UK started preparing an operation to
evacuate and rescue to their rescuers it
was about resettling their clients I'm
talking about white helmet members to
Jordan with further resettlement to a
number of Western countries as is known
at the NATO summit in Brussels in July
2018 Canada's Minister foreign affairs
called upon their partners in the
Alliance to join in this initiated by
making an example of special easing of
the national law to help immigrants in
Canada as it turned out later it was it
didn't go as smoothly in reality firstly
Western donors we shall so persistently
and generously supported the arrest
clients for several years faced
disproportionately high requirements as
far as citizenship resettlement and
employments are concerned but probably
they are aware that these people thought
that these countries oh something to
them for the information the work they
did for these countries in exchange for
comfortable state the protectors of
white helmet members in also a London
and all the supervising capitals who are
quiet aware of the proven Sabbath
sabotage training and terrorist skills
of a
they have a food for thought I think as
something to be afraid of if they settle
them in their countries indeed that's
the only explanation we find for the
fact that the Ottawa initiative intended
for three to four weeks loses traction
in still uncompleted on the other hand
there is probably strong inclination to
maintain and support white helmet
reserves in Syria in the political
circles of Western allies whose
provocations and sabotages now feed so
naturally into the tactics of terrorists
losing more and more ground in the
country we have also received a few
questions regarding the incident around
the American Navy ships in the Gulf we
understand Terrance sharp criticism
regarding American military who
exercises provocative and dangerous
maneuvers near Iranian shores in the
Persian Gulf on the 15th of April Moscow
has always considered stability and
security in the Gulf is one of the key
factors the int infers the situation in
a broader regional context following the
same logic we launched a well known
initiative about the collective security
in the region we call on the parties to
show maximum restraint and care and not
to fall for provocations and aggressive
rhetoric and to act in accordance with
the existing international norms and
rules
we believe that illegal unilateral
sanctions that prevent a number of
countries from saving their citizens
lives from the epidemic need to be
halted for humanitarian concerns instead
of maneuvers it would be much more
fitting to organise green corridors in
the current situation a couple of days
ago the NPT review conference was
supposed to begin its work in New York
but the epidemiological situation in the
world and in the u.s. changed that plan
States Parties to the NPT chose to
postpone the review conference it should
be held no later than in April 20-21 the
exact dates will be decided upon in
accordance with the end of the epidemic
and the schedule of international events
Russia confirmed its agreement with this
decision we consider the review
conference as one of the most important
tools of consolidated efforts by the
international community to strengthen
the nuclear non-proliferation regime we
hope that it will be held successfully
it's essential that all parties reaffirm
their commitment to the NPT girls and
their obligations they are under Russia
is ready for active cooperation with all
interested parties on all aspects of the
NPT review we've taken note on a
material published on the do as website
it was about the low-yield nuclear
warhead that was created in the SDW 76
tomb and about them equipping the
Trident to SLBMs the need to develop and
deploy low-yield nuclear weapons is
represented by the yes as its relaxed
reaction to the strengthening of global
threats first and foremost the increase
of nuclear capacity of Russia and China
as we have already said on a number of
occasions we believe that such a stop is
dangerous and destabilizing will believe
that apparently the u.s. is purposefully
eliminating the difference between
strategic and non strategic nuclear
weapons which inevitably brings about
lowering the nuclear threshold and
increases the threat of a nuclear
contact conflict it's not just our
opinion the same opinion was voiced by
reputable American academics in
Juden in the US Congress I reiterate all
attack with the use of an American
submarine launched ballistic missile
regardless of whether it's no yield or
not will be considered to be a nuclear
attack and those who want to speak about
the flexibility of the American nuclear
potential everyone who wants to speak
about it need to realize that according
to the Russian military doctrine such
actions will be considered as the
foundation for response with the use of
nuclear weapons by us another subject
we've noted the preparation of Ukrainian
military by Norwegian troops it's not
worthy that the material published on
Donbass insider website which was about
ten Norwegians and three Swedes that
went to Ukraine to Kiev and its
surroundings on a study tour was
republished by a number of Norwegian
media outlets Norway does not deny that
the information was largely true and a
group of Norwegian Air Force Academy
employees I quote visited a couple of
training camps in Ukraine end of quote
the main goal of this trip was to grasp
an understanding of the situation in
Ukraine and means of hybrid warfare this
episode is just another one in the
string of example of systemic support by
Norway to Kiev as we know Oslo
unequivocally supported the
anti-constitutional coup d'etat in Kiev
and after this was very active in
assisting Ukraine in developing its
military potential we believe that Oslo
should realize its share of
responsibility for a Kiev's current line
in Donetsk People's Republic and Lugansk
People's Republic we hope that instead
of these destructive actions Norway ways
use will use its authority and influence
on Ukraine to make it compliant with the
Minsk agreements a couple of days ago
the Latvian Saeima
adopted in their final reading
legislative amendments that prohibit
wearing Soviet uniform during public
events which is now in this country is
equated I dread to say it but it is
equated to fascist uniforms the official
Regas persistence in rewriting the
historic realities is no longer
surprising naturally we could understand
that these undignified actions that
should be below the dignity of people
who believe in historic truth it was
apparent though that such actions will
continue but we couldn't imagine that
they would go as far however it was not
unexpected all that Latvian
parliamentarians burning desire to time
their militias and initiatives to
coincide with the 75th anniversary of
the great victory over the brown plague
will happen what about the uniforms of
other and to Hitler coalition countries
can you wear it or no longer we have
also received a number of questions
regarding the Czech medium that
published bogus stories and
disinformation pieces over the past few
days they were rather active in that
recently once again we see that Prague
is far from stopping on Monday a Czech
media outlet published some results of a
journalist investigation according to
which Russia intends to physically
eliminate the initiators of the
demolition of monument to Konev in
prague via its embassy in prague and
that russia
alergic lease and a secret agent with
poison in his suitcase to prague to that
and such fantasies do not stand up to
scrutiny one cannot describe down one
cannot give any evaluation that's
another rude provocation verging on
delirium it was initiated by czech
forces that want to impair Russian Czech
Relations whatever the cost
we believe that Frank should be very
clear about how serious the consequences
of the use of such methods and
manipulations will be there is good news
though on the 3rd of April a reputable
American media outlet Foreign Affairs
published an article named yes the name
wasn't rather unusual for American media
it was called to Russia With Love what
was this article about it is noteworthy
that it was prepared by American
professors and it contains interesting
sociological studies that are more of
interest for Americans rather than for
us because there is an apparent deficit
of information in America this
publication drew our attention by
evaluations of the current Crimean
realities that are not standard for the
Western palate illogical community the
article also spoke about the Crimean
Peninsula inhabitants reaction to these
events and I quote when Ukrainian
activists and Western politicians
claimed that the residents of Crimea are
living under occupation they mistake the
experience of some of X of
for the experience for all end of quote
once again that was a quote from an
article written by Americans based on a
sociological research this idea is
further corroborated by polls among
crimeans conducted in 2014 and 2019 at
the request of scientists from an
independent sociological group founded
by the National Science Foundation which
is financed by the US Congress it turns
out that in the u.s. academic community
there is a new trend for objective
analysis of the results of Crimea's
reunification with Russia amid a thick
fog of distortions blatant
disinformation and propagandists that
stereotypes rays of the truth begin to
shine we finally see a lucid approach to
the issue that has been concerning the
West for so very long
I highly recommend to read this article
we are going to provide you a link in
the text in the transcript of this
briefing such a revaluation was bound to
provoke outrage in Kiev and the
Ukrainian foreign minister made the
magazine to publish an alternative
material which was naturally full of old
entired
accusations against Russia in defiance
of all the laws of logic causes are
substituted with consequences and the
authors ignored the genesis and the
evolution of the situation in Crimea
it's key political and legal aspects to
accommodate nita discipline and EU
solidarity the interpret unilaterally
norms and principles of the
international law in question the right
of peoples for self-determination by
referendum
the truth is that the crimeans have a
strong sense of belonging to the heroic
past of our people and they repulse the
foreign issued the values of my done
imposed on them from the outside they
refused to be pawns in someone else's
game they chose to define their future
and that of the peninsula by themselves
and now I quote foreign affairs once
again they are reasonably happy to
believe in in Russia end of quote
it is regrettable that Kiev despite the
historic genetic and civilizational ties
along with economic cultural and
familial relations between our nation's
allowed themselves to be ranked in a
blatantly anti-russian project having
fallen into the trap set out for them by
their protectors
however they are bound to snap back to
reality in the end the EU is not waiting
for Ukraine to be its full member
regarding Ukraine they have a Logan the
aunt goal is nothing the movement is
everything as long as this movement is
against Russia
you know the illusion is being dispelled
and one cannot ignore the reality any
longer further on we are bound to see
more truthful information about these
events including on the pages of
American medium more about this
information though over the past couple
of weeks we've seen another onslaught of
disinformation a disinformation pandemic
epidemic of fakes
and in this strange disinformation
campaign Russia happens just so happens
to play one of the key roles why is it
being done there are probably a number
of reasons but our country as well as
some other countries faced accusations
of sowing discord in the Western
community and its structures including
the NATO and the EU we see re-emergence
of a stereotype that everything that
comes from Russia is dangerous many of
the problems Western countries and other
countries are facing now are systemic
and deep-seated a lot has been said
about the digital revolutions challenges
for a democracy and social model of
market economy globalization's
influence on identity and these
projections for international security
some of our Western colleagues do not
trouble themselves with analyzing the
root causes of their problems as and as
is their habit try to attribute them to
some external forces and following the
beaten route they mean Russia by these
forces although right now we have new
characters China the WHU shows we have
already grown the cast grown accustomed
to the fact that when our partners don't
like the outcomes of Elections or
referendums they accuse Russia of
interference in their preparation and
organization when their immigration
policy of open doors proves itself
inefficient Russia is presented as the
one responsible for generating refugee
flows to Europe
and in the era of electronic
technologies in electoral processes our
country is permanently credited with
implication in stimulating separatist
movements and supporting Euroskeptic
attitudes and cyberattacks a new subject
we emerged they now speculate on the
corona virus epidemic NATO and EU spread
out rumors that Moscow is allegedly
using this situation in the Western
countries to discredit the transatlantic
unity and the Euro integration ideas
they also alleged that Russia is trying
to represent the situation as if Western
democracies both collectively and
individually are failing to curb the
pandemic and its consequences let us
hear what Western officials have to say
on that matter
it wasn't behind closed doors it wasn't
in a tight crib prime ministers of Spain
and Italy warned about the same thing in
their public remarks the same was said
by the French Minister of State in
charge of European affairs the EU
European Commission Commission President
personal Andra lion went further and
conferred official apologies to Italy
for a lack of efficiency of measures
undertaken by the European Commission at
the initial stage of the pandemic former
president of the European Council and
currently the head of the European
People's Party Donald Tusk you see
that's a man very closely related to
urine integration to Brussels to
politics and to the views of those who
lead the EU said in his interview to Der
Spiegel
that he wouldn't rule out the
dissolution of the EU as the result of
the
oh no crisis he also characterized the
situation in sounds or in European
countries as a catastrophe once again it
wasn't Russia who said it these are the
evaluations that were given by Europeans
themselves
speaking of transatlantic ties hardly
anyone could give a huge blow to them
than the United States itself which it
did in March they made a decision to
halt flights with Europe and according
to some information we are ready to in
the median they confiscated a shipment
of medical masks that were destined for
German law enforcers once again we need
to double-check this information but
there was some articles about it in
Western medium speaking of this
information one of well-known European
publications política admitted that the
majority of fake stories in the media
were generated by Europeans who are
alarmed by information in the press and
looking for support representatives of
the EU and individual European countries
are making statements about the
situation both in the EU and on the
national level interestingly the
sharpness of these statements
tenfold stronger is this temple'
stronger than whatever was previously
said in their address by Russian
officials but them they are not accused
of any intentions to undermine democracy
spread misinformation or the use of
misinformation to undermine the unity of
democracies so what is the question
about is it the issue of
real problems of countries or is it the
problem who formulates actual issues
bring them into lights turns out reality
is something this liberal community
doesn't want doesn't want to hear and
maybe cannot hear and takes makes every
effort to make sure this truth is never
never comes out then either way needs to
be taken the EU has to decide within
itself who among the EU members in
Brussels can speak and deliver the only
truth and the rest will be just
parroting them otherwise if we don't
reach this concept then they should stop
accusing Russia blunt criticizing
statements are made by these countries
representatives themselves in Russia has
nothing to do with it in conclusion the
situation in the Western community
revealed through the pandemic is
officially recognized by its countries
officials and and rather frankly at that
however it is Russia who Western
propagandistic use of intentions to
undermine the unity of democracies they
do that instead of learning right
lessons from the current and paralleled
crisis and focusing and looking for a
common way forward to overcome its it
causes a lots of surprise there is
another topic that is concerning both to
us and our diplomats Russian citizens
and their family members we were alarmed
by information
that in the US prison of Danbury and we
have commented on this situation many
times this prison
among other inmates has the Russian
national bagdana Oh Sai Baba so the
information was that one of residents of
this prison was tested positive for the
corona virus we contacted our compatriot
according to her information she feels
ok now nevertheless it is the second
casing of the infection reported from
this penitentiary facility this week for
this reason our embassy to Washington
sent a note to Department of State
requiring to hold the medical check-up
for the Russian with the relevant tests
obviously then BRE whose prisoners also
include the Russian pilot Konstantin
Yara shankha amidst the continued growth
of infection cases in the United States
the faces a critical situation a massive
outbreak of infection cases among the
inmates can happen any time we sensitize
our US counterparts to this situation to
our nationals situation and we call upon
them to free both osipov and ER shank as
well as every russian who is in this
country under investigation or sentenced
to prisons recently of rather in in a
couple of days we're going to see the
60th anniversary of establishing
diplomatic relations with relations
between the Russian Federation and the
Republic of toga the they are our
longtime longtime France and they have
gone a long way of national liberation
and win the right to determine their own
future the cost of toga from the period
of the 15th to the 19th century
one of the key areas of slave trade in
western Africa and that's why it was
dubbed slave coast in the late 19th
century the colonial occupation of the
modern target began and until 1914 the
country was under the German protector
ship during World War one the country
was occupied by by British and French
forces and only in April 1960 toga
gained independence and in 1963 received
its official name of the tunngle is
Republic today as we approach the 60th
anniversary of establishing diplomatic
relations between our countries we can
positively state that over the recent
period you have managed to build a
meaningful and fruitful political
dialogue it is based on similar views of
our countries on the majority of topical
issues of today there is intensification
of engagements between foreign policy
departmental country's legal framework
has been updated within the United
Nations and other international
organizations joint steps are being
taken to consolidate peace stability and
security our bilateral cooperation
received the cathedral considerable
impetus thanks to the participation of
the tunngle a delegation headed by the
country's president in the Economic
Forum and some is Russia Africa based on
the results of these meetings we
outlined ways to strengthen our
partnership in a number of areas
including trade economic investment
humanitarian spheres and according to
joint opinions there is a good potential
for enhancing cooperation agriculture
energy infrastructure and development of
mineral resources we cordially
congratulate toggle on our joint
remarkable date and we reiterate our
commitment to further dynamic
development of vina entire sets of
Russian Congolese relations and we wish
peace prosperity and well-being to the
people of the Congo Republic now we turn
to questions and answer sessions some of
them I have already addressed
there is one question from International
Life magazine about the discussion
between Sergey Lavrov and always see
secretary-general Graham eager about the
monitoring mission of all see in Ukraine
how it's going to be affected by the
coronavirus considering the pandemic
outbreak oldfield presences of the OSI
were temporarily suspended based on
prevention instructions of local
authorities they're mostly working
remotely as to the special monitoring
mission of the OSI in Ukraine out of 729
international observers 150 people more
than that figure returned to their
respective countries DNR and LNR
Authority has established Disease
Control and Prevention requirements to
the movement of SMM observers guided by
the need to care about the health of the
population Denese Koval ganske regions
and the workers of the mission during
the telephone conversation between
secretary-general gramming Greer and the
Minister on the 27th of April Sergei
Lavrov emphasized the full justification
of these measures and called upon the
nation to establish relevant dialogue
with disease prevention authorities of
Donetsk Lugansk and we proceed from the
assumption that the special monitoring
mission of the you see in Ukraine will
continue before may its mandate
according to the decision of a C
permanent council until the 31st of
March 3 2021
now media outlet news rather about the
air crash of mh17 on the 23rd of April
the district court of The Hague
supported the decision of the
investigation authorities not to
disclose 12 out of 13 witnesses what how
it's going to affect the court
proceedings thank you for a question
first of all Russia is not a party of
these court press
ceilings but charges has been brought
against three Russian nationals so we
are following closely the developments
what is going on there if the rights
have been upheld it is important for
justice that the process really is open
and stays within the the framework of
the law in order for the process take
into consideration opinions of both
parties and in order to demonstrate
independence and unbiased nature process
it has been decided to make the hearings
public and online broadcasting has been
organized from the courtroom to whether
this decree of the status of witnesses
meets this criteria without that and I
will explain as is known the
prosecutor's office of the Netherlands
during the first hearings in March 2000
xx stated that it is a phrase of the
lives of witnesses what their specific
threats are was not clarified
nevertheless such statements gave
grounds to the investigation court in
2018-2019 to refer to these witnesses as
founded threat therefore they were
concealed their personalities we
considered concealed attorneys of one of
the suspects protests against this
decision of the judge since this curtain
of secrecy does not allow the defense to
cast witness's testimony into doubt we
see that they Co did not support the
defense nevertheless and turn down the
demands of attorneys to disclose
personalities of 12 out of 13 witnesses
interestingly the court does not even
conceal the fact that in doing so they
violated the criminal
seizure coated velocity of the
Netherlands in more than one in fact
instead in 11 out of 13 cases they took
into account only the opinion of the
prosecutor's office such a violation
from rules and violation of the law
effectively the judges considered it
necessary as this stated because of the
gravity of the crime and seriousness of
accusations it is a rather strange
attitude to justice we see from the very
beginning of the court proceedings which
is of special importance in the
Netherlands while emphasizing high
standards of the entire justice system
and legal literacy of their judges
contradictory decisions have been taken
which are only technical at first sight
in fact the decision of anonymous
attitude can have far-reaching
consequences and there will be in terms
of trust to the final decision the court
now another question how can you comment
on the preparations of the comprehensive
partnership declaration to Russians
Becca Stan indeed there has been they
have been preparations between the two
countries it is intended that this
treaty enshrine significant progress in
our cooperation contribute to further
engagements in foreign policy security
economy finances energy transportation
people-to-people ties including monthly
twenty creative aspect this is going to
be a new stage in the implementation of
fundamental principles of Russians
Baker's and relations set out in the
strategic partnership treaty between the
Russian Federation the Republic of
Uzbekistan dated 16th of June 2004
Treaty of alliance between the respect
raishin the Republic of Uzbekistan dated
the 14th of November 2005 and
declaration of strength
strategic partnership between the
Russian Federation and the Republicans
biggest undated the 4th of June 2012 as
to the adoption of this declaration
this is competence of the heads of
states of state all this information
will be further commands upon by their
relevant offices and here thanking you
and leaving until the next time thank
you